welcome to this video playing yvaine and
I vain I don't know ok I'm going forward
twins gambit let's stay solid yeah
shooting for that night h5 set up that
is special or nowadays some more they
always play h6 protect don't know why ok
we will see how this works I think this
works out why this usually canceling
long some people cancel short but I'm
not so um I'm quite well equipped for m4
short canceling worldwide
you
I can actually go to g7 or to f6 both is
quite sensible I'll go G so it's so not
quite clear to me both other set is
feasible right there okay okay I'm
putting the King to be eight first it
feels a bit uncomfortable on the C file
you want black ideas to play h5 and try
to play against this G for porn here
what's players not that clear actually
sometimes they play for Knight a 40 and
Roxy one play on the C file on the
queenside but that doesn't look very
young tempting here as the night on f4
and all that doesn't add up ok so I'll
get this traded that's nice oh it's
playing h4 voluntarily surprising
actually I get night at five to a tech
h4 I ok maybe he has to do it any way
possible ok
let's jump right in can always hope for
be three okay it won't happen one point
is that right sometimes get the e5
square for his no idea that's something
to be be aware of okay if I cannot
easily play of six this is an issue oh
by the way maybe I should play of six
takes Queen takes a choice hard to
defend actually hmm interesting I'm
going for that maybe I'm totally
misjudging things but it looks
interesting trying to where I can go
group g1 can go group g1 well here night
a three as a move actually temple yeah I
think I'll go for that it's a temple and
then I can take g5 we can only check it
once anyway I'm going for that
and night coming to a fire that is said
is some cause for concern and if I
played that right hmm maybe not the
night coming to the 5s is really
uncomfortable a six is to have a good
square and be five or goods well yeah
that I can actually retreat the noid
well at least I man on the clock has
small victories ok let's need to get
this back into the game
okay so if i take g5 is going for night
36 yeah hmm yeah it's not easy to two
defenders in the first place group t6
looks it's not exactly what you what you
dream about now I played this badly
badly badly I guess hmm why can I not
take now I scooped you bond n no I don't
know ok let's go 496 see if i can trade
one of the nights i'm not actually
threatening this in the first place sg6
is hanging I can however this is
protected
good night f cell we are bloody nights
too many nights deeply irritating
c61 hanging with check
wow I have no idea what to do that
doesn't look good Andy too and maybe
maybe rupee aid and just take that damn
night only five I can actually take on
g6 now as his 7s hanging at the end no
his flying is playing for the plane
Chang the big money here Queen B 6
checkers the thing
and I let the fire that's what I'm also
afraid of but ok let's seem for Queen to
be seven here my can maybe just play for
that was my idea get the Queen over to
help in defense now time morning check
check check check check on the chicks
who and I hope my age pawn is Sir is
doing doing something good now check
white resigns who it wasn't good I don't
think that was a good position now maybe
initially but um but yeah yeah I was
happy I was really happy but with the
night coming to a five but the night on
e5 is really annoying it really is
annoying I have six and now you went and
now maybe I should just go back the
thing is what I wanted never
materialized I never could take on g5 it
was epic what support and now I'm stuck
in this position and that isn't great it
really isn't there was certainly better
options for wine
here what is just better right here you
can take jus 6m what I what I said
instead he took on c6 you can take on g6
like this because here here here then
the night is hanging so after this I'm
basically just this pawn down and deaf
and I'm lost yeah this i'm not sure i
mean this still looks like white is
chances but it is not the objectively
best solution oh here you can win with
Queen B 6 okay I should have gone to a 7
ok so this wins yeah I have this is the
only move that continues the game at
least with the quality check check check
check now he's still ok up to him but um
easiest relatively easiest would have
been to take him and then well it
continues very tough this seems to be a
draw I'm threatening made him this is
some kind of boat row to a perpetual
here check check check no no this is
probably losing you know yeah it's
probably lost I'm just I'm just too
quick here with with my nights at the
age pod so there was a very lucky win he
played that very well up to this point
where he took on c6 which does not seem
to be the best but still and probably
okay check this seems to be playable for
black look here and then the fantastic
looking them tonight 28 yeah but if it
holds it also can you do
remarkable yeah it's um it's um it would
have been much easier to take on g6 fam
I don't think I would have gotten out of
that one okay thanks for watching